20 heures la pluie ne décourage pas les
consommateurs place du théâtre
ils sont des dizaines à s'installer pour
trinquer une dernière fois avant le
couvre-feu pendant six semaines
les restaurants vont se plier aux
nouvelles mesures sanitaires à 21h
fermeture des portes dans cette
brasserie ont mis sur une carte plus
cohérente pour attirer des clients même
en journée des solutions pour les jeunes
qui n'ont pas forcément les tunes
poursuivre elle va trouver faire à
manger des petits trucs pour qu'ils
puissent continuer à venir de rentrer
dans leur budget à tous et que tout le
monde puisse venir encore même si les
horaires vont se décaler tout le monde
puisse venir encore si les brasseries
peuvent continuer à prendre des
réservations le jour les bars de ferme
jusqu'à début décembre
pour ce gérant c'est l'incompréhension
il avait déjà repoussé l'ouverture de
son nouveau bar à cause du confinement
trois mois plus tard il doit baisser le
rideau effectivement c'est pas forcément
normal que les restaurants restent
ouverts et que nous les barons n'est
fait mais on subit surtout pendant que
les bars du centre-ville range une
dernière fois leurs terrasses les
clients eux profite des quelques moments
de vie nocturne
car ce soir déambuler dans la rue après
21h pourra être sanctionné d'une amende
de 135 euros